dr markus söder ersparen
wirtschaftsminister hubert aiwanger und
gesundheitsministerin melanie huml das
prozedere wird dieselbe sein wie gestern
journalisten sind zugeschaltet alles
wird per stream übertragen und fragen
sind dann im anschluss zugelassen
herr ministerpräsident meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ich bedanke
mich sehr dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister holzes
kabinett kommen
aber wir haben gemeinsame analyse der
situation der auswirkungen der
möglichkeiten der maßnahme gesprochen
es ist für den freistaat bayern von ganz
großer bedeutung dass wir in dieser zeit
in dieser phase ein weitgehend
einheitliches vorgehen haben das werk
einen kompetenz-wirrwarr keine kompetenz
kann haus gekommen so dass die behörden
alle in eine richtung sich
gemeinschaftlich gewicht mitteln und das
vor dieser unglaublich großen
bewährungsprobe differenz steht auch der
gemeinsame geist für allen ergehen
lassen
der freistaat bayern ist an einigen
punkten übrigens immer in absprache mit
dem bundesgesundheitsminister an manchen
stellen etwas voran gegangen was auch
daran liegt dass wir natürlich besonders
betroffen sind als grenzregion besonders
betroffen sind in der nähe zu österreich
in italien
deswegen haben wir sowohl bei den
schulschließungen als auch bei den
maßnahmen die wir am montag verkündet
haben ein stück weit auch tempo gemacht
wir freuen uns natürlich sehr dass
nahezu alle bundesländer im gleichklang
sind auch der bund und das wir da die
richtung liegt nur definieren sondern
auch das tempo gemeinsam synchronisiert
ganz wichtig ist er heute darüber
beraten
die klare botschaft es gibt kein anlass
zur panik aber es gibt anlass zu sorge
wir bitten sie alle maßnahmen die
getroffen werden zu unterstützen
mitzugehen aus zurück sicht für andere
auch wenn die symptome nach wie vor so
sind das ist die derzeitige
wissenschaftliche lage medizinische
auffassung dass über 80 prozent rund 80
prozent keine leichte symptome haben
müssen wir aus rücksicht vor den
eltern darauf achten vor den
risikopatienten dass wir dort keine
ansteckung vornehmen und deswegen auch
besonders darauf achten dieser charakter
test in unserer gesellschaft jetzt zu
erfahren hat wird viel gutes
herausfordern wird viel gutes bringen
wird aber auch manche schwierigkeiten
zeigen auf beides wollen wir uns
einstellen unvorbereitet sein deswegen
bitte auch keine hamsterkäufe zu machen
keine sonder bargeldabhebungen
der reguläre verlauf das reguläre leben
geht weiter es gibt einschränkungen die
müssen wir jetzt machen die sind auch
wichtig um zu verhindern dass sich die
infektionen erweitern ist doch wichtig
um unserem gesundheitssystem die
möglichkeit zu geben dann präzise und
gut zu reagieren
deswegen haben wir heute einen
umfangreichen maßnahmenkatalog noch
einmal geschlossen
erstens wir haben jetzt beschlossen den
katastrophenfall den wäre ja ausgerufen
zu ergänzen um den entsprechenden
katastrophen stark die leitung liegt ab
jetzt in der staatskanzlei
von hier aus wird koordiniert und
strukturiert zweitens wir stellen neue
400 400 mitarbeiter in den
gesundheitsbehörden an das natürlich
abordnungen geschehen von anderen
verwaltungsbehörden die jetzt weniger im
moment gefordert sind 400 das ist ganz
wichtig um die bislang doch sehr
überlasteten gesundheitsämter auch bei
den telefonnummern und 16 17
entsprechend zu entlasten und auch zu
helfen
es gibt deswegen weil nicht jeder muss
arzt sein sondern es sind viel auch
telefonate tätigkeiten oder auch
abklärung wer mit wem in kontaktperson
war
dort wird es eine massive entlastung des
medizinischen personals in den
gesundheitsämtern bringen
bei den krankenhäusern habt ihr noch mal
klar festgelegt dass wir eine verfügung
rausgeben dass alle für alle
krankenhäuser für sohn
vorsorgeeinrichtungen dass die regel
gilt ob es müssen getätigt werden wenn
sie medizinisch notwendig sind soweit es
aber nicht sind schönheits-op es
beispielsweise die europäische sache
vielleicht manche hüfte die auch in 12
monaten noch gemacht werden kann dies in
so manchen augen sachen all diese dinge
gibt es unendlich viele die man schieben
kann
die bieten wir nicht nur bitten wir die
weißen wie anzuschieben
um kapazitäten zu haben der
hauptunterschied bislang ist dass wir
vier fünf wochen glaube ich es natürlich
diese muster vor italien sind es kann
sein dass von einem auf den anderen tag
die infektionen nach oben schnell und
genau für den moment für diesen
zeitpunkt müssen wir jetzt gerüstet sein
also wichtig kapazitäten vorzuhalten
das heißt bedeutet dass wir auch die
uniklinika völlig darauf ausrichten die
uniklinika werden ab jetzt primär
versorgen und nicht forschen bereits
jetzt den 500 medizinstudenten aktiviert
waren zur unterstützung des können am
ende bis zu 5000 sein die dann ihren
dienst leisten da mein dankeschön an
studentinnen und studenten die ihr
bereits jetzt ihre tätigkeit leisten
sich einbringen werden
das ist ein hohes maß an bereitschaft
der uniklinik es viele in vielen dank
dafür
wichtig für uns ist dass wir bei den
kliniken die reserven halten
das sind besonders wichtig reha kliniken
beispielsweise wenn in bayern höchstmaß
eine besonders starke struktur von reha
kliniken diese reha kliniken werden uns
helfen die möglichkeit von
intensivbetten zu erweitern
wir prüfen auch ob es dann für leichtere
fälle ergänzungs möglichkeiten geben
kann sei es in hotels die nicht mehr
genutzt werden oder in anderen bereichen
wir wollen breit aufgestellt sein damit
dieser dann im zweiten fall ein bett
finden kann wenn es beim thema
materialien ist das ganz wichtig wir
danken den bundesgesundheitsminister
sehr dass er persönlich mit hohem
einsatz dahinter erst die material
fragen zu klären
material fragen stellen sich ein
teilweise an schutzmasken atemgeräte und
auch die laborkapazitäten wir geben
heute die möglichkeiten sieht
entsprechend zu regeln
wir sagen eindeutig dass wir da jetzt
alle maßnahmen treffen werden bis hin zu
beschlagnahmungen um dafür zu sorgen
dass alles nicht nur kommt sondern dann
auch der ableitung genutzt wird dh
meldepflicht für atemgeräte zu haben
+ neue zu kaufen bei den schutzmasken
dafür zu sorgen dass die bestellungen
getätigt worden sind vom bund aber vom
land ankommen
und ich sagte übrigens auch ganz
eindeutig wir haben den inneminister
gebeten dafür zu sorgen
man sei auch dann die entsprechenden
bestellungen eingehen was schutzmasken
gewisse arten geräte auch mit sichern
soll beispielsweise bei den
kassenärztlichen vereinigungen denn es
gibt bereits gestern gab es einen fall
in einem krankenhaus in nordrhein
westfalen das da bewusstes gestohlen
wurde
das ist einer der negativen seiten die
so eine krise dann zeigt wir wollen
darauf entsprechend vorbereitet sein und
da entsprechend helfen
also es waren beschlagnahmung geben es
gibt meldepflichten es wird versucht
auch die gesamten laborkapazitäten
zusammenzubringen denn wir wollen die
taste erhöhen dass sie nicht mehr
personal mit neuen testverfahren die
gerade in der abstimmung sind und ganz
wichtig eben auch mit den
laborkapazitäten private labors die
jetzt zusammengeschaltet werden
ich bin ja verständnis hat morgen wird
das öffentliche leben ziemlich runter
gefahren werden heute bereits die
gesamten freizeiteinrichtungen
sie wissen es sie haben es gelesen sie
haben es gehört danke auch für die
unterstützung und für die bereitschaft
und das verständnis
es wird jetzt noch andere bereiche geben
ab morgen wird die geschäfte
heruntergefahren
wir haben heute entsprechende absprache
mit dem bund noch einige ergänzungen
dazu getroffen die wir dass wir
beispielsweise bei hotels dass die
touristischen übernachtungen nicht
möglich sind nur wenn es darum geht so
nicht touristischen zwecken übernachtung
zu machen ist noch zulässig sonst nicht
wichtig für uns ist auch dass wir
generell noch einmal eine einschränkung
vornehmen bei den altenheimen bei der
pflege haben über den krankenhäusern was
des besuchsrechts betrifft weil wir da
auch weiter das ganze konzentrieren
wollen
gransee busreisen werden verboten wir
stellen noch mal ganz klar ein
gastronomiebereich das ist wichtig dass
wir auf der einen seite ja das wird ab
morgen gelten und bis 15 uhr bei
speiselokalen die öffnungs möglichkeit
haben nur noch bis 15 dies gilt übrigens
auch ganz klar für den bereich
biergarten abend erlassen
und auch andere bereiche wie eistee also
das gilt auch für all diese bereiche
weil wir nicht richtig finden das dann
quasi autorin
gastronomiebereich das nachgeholt wird
was sind in österreich nicht möglich ist
deswegen wird es noch ergänzt alles
übrigens dort wo ein kontakt künftig
möglich ist bei allen formen von
dienstleistern wie beispielsweise fürs
hören möchten wir in den mindestabstand
von eineinhalb metern zwischen dem
kunden haben und es sollen sich
interessant auch nie mehr als zehn
personen im wartebereich befinden
wir bitten darauf rücksicht zu nehmen
denn es geht um den schutz auch der
menschen arbeitnehmern arbeitnehmer die
dort arbeiten auf der einen seite und
auf der anderen seite eben auch die
kundschaft selters geschützten als wir
wollen das öffentliche leben
herunterfahren
wir wollen aber die versorgung mit
wichtigen dienstleistungen und auch mit
lebensmitteln weiter aufrechterhalten
zum lebensmittelbereich ist es noch so
gar nichts sagen darf dass wir uns noch
mit allen einzelhandelsketten treffen um
da auch dafür sorgen dass die
lieferungen möglich sind wir sind auch
nochmal mit dem bund im engen gespräch
dass bei der jetzigen grenzkontrolle
die warenlieferungen optimal gestaltet
werden es könnte sein dass wir
möglicherweise an den grenzübergängen
grüne spuren für lkws brauchen die
insbesondere waren die forderungen ins
land bringen damit die versorgungslage
für die bevölkerung nicht nur jetzt
sondern auch für die nächsten wochen
optimal gesichert ist zur
versorgungslage gehört übrigens auch
eine wirtschafts minister sehr dankbar
dass wir bei diesen schutz materialien
die wir haben auch dafür sorgen dass wir
und das alles gute für aus eigene
kapazitäten aufbauen
insbesondere was schutzmasken mittels
damit ihr unabhängiger werden von den
bestellungen aus dem ausland sie können
nämlich das einschätzen das
wahrscheinlich in der ganzen welt bedarf
ist und dass da auch nicht nur
schindluder betrieben dass das geld
begriff sondern auch nationale nasen und
leide an der stelle möglich sind die
stattfinden wir haben dann und das ist
uns ganz wichtig noch einmal die
rechtlichen grundlagen gelegt durch
beschluss was das geld betrifft die
unterstützung zehn milliarden euro
unseren schutzschirm sie wissen ist was
wir darunter fassen zum einerseits
umfangreiche steuerstundungen die ab
jetzt greifen können
die finanzämter sind bereit für die
betriebe für die unternehmen die
darunter leiden
zum zweiten dass bürgschaftsrahmen für
die lfa weiter auf 500 mio
eine halbe werde alec bedeutet eine
ausfallbürgschaft wenn es um kredite
geht die bei normalen ausmachen sind
unser sofort geld und sofort hilfe die
jetzt schon zwischen 35.000 euro dass
wirtschaftsminister mit finanzminister
im haben die entsprechenden grundlagen
gelegt ab morgen wird es dazu über die
homepage die entsprechenden lade
formulare käme also die antragsformulare
herunterladen kann und bereits ab
freitag gibt es die möglichkeit von
zeichnen wenn die entsprechenden
unterlagen eingereicht werden so schnell
so direkt hilft nur der freistaat bayern
an der stelle
wir wollen der wirklich niemand allein
was wir bitten den bund sowohl die
lohnfortzahlung im krankheitsfall als
auch das kurzarbeitergeld als auch das
arbeitslosengeld anzupassen auf die
korona aus förderung dann ist wird
unternehmen geben die zu machen es wird
unternehmen geben die sich zurückhalten
werden oder ganze unterfangen müssen uns
darauf einstellen damit viele
verpflichtungen die menschen haben
darlehensverträge selber beispielsweise
ihr normales auskommen im film mit der
familie dass das alles gewährleistet
werden kann
wir müssen uns darauf umfassend
vorbereiten das geht nur zusammen wir
leisten schnelle hilfe kein bundesland
leistet so groß und so schnell die hilfe
wir hoffen sehr dass es ein erster
wichtiger impuls wir werden aber
sicherlich bund und die länder nach
steuern müssen
ein letzter punkt oder vorletzter punkt
der mir vielleicht noch wichtig ist
dankeschön an die schulen und die kitas
die betreuung die notfallbetreuung hat
gut funktioniert
wir sind wirklich dankbar auch den
eltern sehr sehr dieses gestern alles
organisiert wurde
wir haben eine notfallbetreuung jetzt
von jeweils knapp einem prozent bei
beiden bei schulen und bei kitas wir
sind da im prozess wir werden es weiter
versuchen gut zu organisieren dass es
klappt und hoffen sehr dass die
betreuung auf dauer gewährleistet ist
für uns eben auch wichtig dass wir
ergänzende angebote machen unsere unser
kultusministerium arbeitet daran ihm
gerade für schüler und schüler was die
vorbereitung auf prüfungen betrifft
abitur angriff
wollen dass keinem schüler ein
entsprechender nachteil entstehen und
letzter punkt der noch ist wir haben
auch beschlossen ein neues bayerisches
infektionsschutzgesetz noch diese woche
zu lassen
das uns neben den einzel verfügungen die
wir bislang treffen eine bessere
gesetzliche grundlage bietet um
entsprechende maßnahmen zu treffen
zuweisung von hilfspersonal der
medizinischen verteilung von kapazitäten
beschlagnahmen möglichkeiten also quasi
eine bessere rechtliche grundlage um das
alles zu erreichen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die lage wird ihnen an den andern tag
der eine glaubt das ist nicht so schlimm
wird einige sind sehr sehr besorgt wir
versuchen richtig maß und mitte zu
finden
aber es gilt nach wie vor nur das primat
der politik medizin die politik richtet
sich nach dem und wir versuchen das
beste an der stelle zu erreichen
meine bitte wie gesagt machen sie alle
mit lassen sie uns unterhalten es gibt
tolle beispiele von ehrenamtlichen
engagement
wir werden übrigens auch dies auf die
dauer finanzieren unterstützen
ehrenamtliches engagement
wenn es um einkaufsmöglichkeiten gilt
gerade für ältere bitte achten sie
darauf wo sie hingehen und was ihr tun
wir haben keine ausgangssperre die wir
hoffen dass die maßnahmen jetzt alle
greifen aber achten sie darauf wo sie
hingehen zu welchem zweck am besten ist
man geht raus wenn man sich versorgen
muss wenn man zu arbeiten muss es ist
ganz wichtig und wenn man anderen
beispielsweise hilft das ist wichtig
jetzt als primäre sache und der
osterurlaub auch da gibt's die
ratschläge oder bundesregierung über
befolgen muss dann und die osterferien
werden in bayern verbracht am besten
daheim
es ist jetzt eine zeit der einschränkung
wir hoffen dass die jetzigen
einschränkungen reichen damit es nicht
noch größere maßnahmen
ställe gibt und dass wir gut durchkommen
unser einziges ziel ist bayern soll
durch diese krise durch kommen dafür
geben wir uns mühe
dafür steht die ganze staatsregierung
parat und wir danken nochmal den punkt
sehr dass uns dabei hilft
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn der
ministerpräsident lieber markus meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren zuerst
einmal möchte ich danken für die gute
zusammenarbeit
wir haben ja hier in bayern in münchen
die erste corona lage gehabt stichwort
webasto und es gab von dem ersten tag an
eine sehr sehr gute zusammenarbeit auch
zwischen dem bund und dem freistaat
bayern auch persönlich aber eben auch
auf allen ebenen und strukturen
ich bin zum seiten beeindruckt einmal
mehr ich war ja nicht zum ersten mal im
bayerischen kabinett zu gast beeindruckt
von der intensität mit der jetzt auch an
diesem thema gearbeitet wird aber vor
allem auch in der klarheit und
konkretheit der maßnahmen ein beispiel
nur dass bis zu 400 beamte mitarbeiter
des öffentlichen dienstes aus anderen
behörden des landes den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst der landkreise und
kreisfreien städte jetzt gehen um vor
ort zu unterstützen macht gerade für die
wichtige arbeit ist der kontakt nach
verfolgung das ist eine der wichtigsten
instrumente die wir haben dann wenn
jemand positiv getestet ist auch
möglichst viele kontakte zu
identifizieren zu kontaktieren zu betten
zu hause zu bleiben
diese zusätzlichen 400 kräfte machen
einen echten unterschied ich glaube das
ist wahrscheinlich in gewisser weise
dann auch wieder stilbildend auch in
andere bereiche hinein
jetzt geht es darum zeit zu gewinnen
zeit zu gewinnen um die ausbreitung des
virus zu verlangsamen und zeit zu
gewinnen um während wir eben sehr stark
ja gerade mit maßnahmen verlangsamen da
auch die intensiv und beatmungs
kapazitäten der krankenhaus kapazitäten
auszubauen und uns vorzubereiten auch in
den kliniken auf die steigende zahl an
patienten die zu erwarten ist und auch
das feuer gerade thema im
doch dort finde ich sehr gut sehr sehr
ja auch vorausschauend wie hier im
freistaat geplant wird in betten frei zu
bekommen da wo kooperationen nicht
notwendig sind wo im planbare eingriffe
verschoben werden können dass wir also
diese zeit jetzt die wir gewinnen auch
durch die maßnahmen die wir ergreifen um
die ausbreitung zu verlangsamen
tatsächlich nutzen zum aufbau der
entsprechenden kapazitäten und um auch
den blick zu nehmen die
bevölkerungsgruppen insbesondere die
älteren und menschen mit vorerkrankungen
auch konzepte zu entwickeln sie
besonders zu schützen
denn genau diese bürgerinnen und bürger
zu schützen das ist jetzt unsere
gemeinsame aufgabe unsere gemeinsame
aufgabe als nation für jeden bürger jede
bürgerin und für uns als menschen
denn genau darum geht es eben gemeinsam
zusammenzustehen immer geführt darauf
hingewiesen
80% anmelde bis symptomfreie verläufe
aber es geht jetzt nicht darum dann für
sich zu denken ist ja nicht so schlimm
sondern wahrzunehmen dass es eben für
andere ein sehr sehr schweren verlauf
bis hin zu lungenentzündung und zur
tödlichen folge geben kann und um dort
möglichst wieder zu schützen stehen wir
es eben gemeinsam zusammen deswegen war
sein wichtigstes wichtiges signal vom
montag dass sich einmal mehr nach der
schulschließung und kindergarten
schließung letzte woche alle
bundesländer auf eine linie geeinigt
haben
das was im föderalismus manchmal etwas
länger braucht in der entscheidung wirkt
dafür dann aber umso effektiver in der
fläche auch der teil ist ja sehr sehr
wichtig ja die entscheidung mag manchmal
ein oder zwei tage länger dauern und
manchmal ist es hilfreich wenn einige
auch die dinge vorantreiben ohne zweifel
aber der föderalismus zeigt seine stärke
eben auch und vor allem und das war
gerade während der kabinettssitzung auch
zu spüren er in der umsetzung wenn dann
eben in 16 bundesländern
ressourcen die auch da sind die
maßnahmen entsprechend umgesetzt werden
können wir erleben einen wahrscheinlich
den tiefsten einschnitt in den alltag
der bürgerinnen und bürger in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
daran gibt es nichts zu beschönigen
jeder von uns braucht ein paar tage um
auch zu realisieren was das tatsächlich
an veränderung bedeutet um sich auch
klar zu werden was das für ein selbst
für den alltag bedeutet und sich auf
diese neue situation einzustellen
das geht in so den bürgerinnen und
bürgern das geht mir so das wird uns
allen so es gibt menschen überall in
europa und auf der welt so die mit den
folgen dieser pandemie und der
entwicklung der letzten wochen umgehen
müssen und das sind ja folgen die ihn
weit über das medizinische hinausgehend
wirtschaftlich gesellschaftlich in ganz
ganz viele bereiche es spielen
gleichzeitig aber eben auch wir leben in
einem starken land wir werden diese
situation bewältigen wenn wir
zusammenstehen wenn wir zusammenarbeiten
auch über alle ebenen wenn wir besonnen
bleiben
das ist sehr sehr wichtig besonnen
bleiben und aufeinander acht geben
ich nehme eine sehr sehr große
bereitschaft war und es sind ja auch
gerade schon ehrenamtliche initiativen
angesprochen worden ich nehme eine sehr
sehr große bereitschaft einander auch zu
helfen um mitzuhelfen und natürlich und
ohne zweifel fällt es dabei nicht leicht
auf dinge zu verzichten die liebgewonnen
sind im alltag in der familie
die freude machen aber genau das ist es
eben worum es gerade geht jetzt auch zu
verzichten auf bestimmte dinge um das
miteinander auch durch diese schwere
zeit zu kommen und den schnee zu
schützen die es besonders schwer haben
oder auch gefährdet sind wenn wir vor
der alternative stehen mitzuhelfen dass
jemand der einem lieb ist in der familie
nicht schwer erkrankt oder aber an einem
fußball spiel teilzunehmen oder essen zu
gehen oder in clubs zu gehen ich glaube
für die allermeisten ist die
entscheidung ziemlich klar sie wollen
natürlich mithelfen dass wir eben
eine schwere erkrankung auch für die
liebsten und für die anderen in der
gesellschaft vermeiden können das ist
genau die entscheidung vor der wir als
gesellschaft stehen
das sind die dinge die wir umsetzen mit
den staatlichen maßnahmen hier heute
geschlossen wurden
aber es funktioniert dem am ende nur
wenn auch jeder in seinem bereich
mithilft und tatsächlich auch achtsam
umgeht damit und solidarität gibt
übrigens auch ein solidaritäts zwischen
generationen werden wir auch darüber
reden dass es ein besonderes risiko für
die älteren und hochbetagten gibt dann
ist es genau die generation die unser
land aufgebaut hat diesen wohlstand in
denen wir heute leben überhaupt erst
möglich macht was wir gerade auch
leisten können
die den erwirtschaftet hat das ist eine
solidarität zwischen den generationen
aber es ist eben auch eine solidarität
von menschen zu menschen mit
vorerkrankungen aller altersgruppen in
dem auch auf unsere besondere
achtsamkeit und auf unsere vorsicht
angewiesen sind
es werden gerade politische entscheidung
getroffen die für viele bürgerinnen und
bürger sehr ernsthafte folgen haben
das reicht von der schwierigen aufgabe
im home office zu arbeiten und
gleichzeitig auch noch die kinder zu
betreuen
bis zu der unsicherheit der zukunft des
eigenen arbeitsplatzes
da gibt es auch nichts auf die leichte
schulter zu nehmen das sind massive
veränderungen für viele bürgerinnen und
bürger die jetzt durch entscheidungen
des staates entscheidungen die wir
treffen auf einmal in eine ganz ganz
andere lage hinein kommen und ich bin
mir der folgen die das für die
bürgerinnen und bürger hat sehr sehr
bewusst und deswegen auch sehr sehr
dankbar dass neben den maßnahmen der
bundesregierung auch die landesregierung
hier in bayern auch mit dem 10
milliarden paket das sehr klare signal
auch setzt der unterstützung an die
bürgerinnen und bürger gerade auch in
den wirtschaftlichen folgen
jetzt ist eine zeit der höchstbelastung
für alle die im gesundheitswesen tätig
sind
das kann man gar nicht oft genug sagen
der ärztinnen und ärzte die pflegekräfte
die sanitäter die apotheker alle anderen
die im gesundheitswesen arbeiten können
eben nicht ins home office in die
heimarbeit sie sind diejenigen auf die
wir uns jetzt verlassen jeden tag auch
in der medizinischen versorgung vor ort
in den kliniken in den praxen
apotheken in den
gesundheitseinrichtungen sie sind
diejenigen die für uns da sind an
vorderster front in diesem kampf gegen
das corona virus und wir alle können sie
dabei unterstützen in diesem kampf wenn
wir dann wenn es eben möglich ist zu
hause bleiben deswegen möchte ich sie
abschließend um etwas bitten
in diesen zeiten schenken sie dem
verkäufer der verkäuferin im supermarkt
in der region in der drogerie vielleicht
einfach mein lächeln oder dem lkw-fahrer
dem logistik lieferanten derjenige der
mithilft dass wir alle gut versorgt sind
einen freundlichen wink und schenken sie
vor allem all denjenigen die gerade
unter starken stress aber in ihre geduld
und ihre mittel wenn ich einsetzen und
gehen sie nach vielen vielen dank auch
den bundesgesundheitsminister bestimmt
ganz glaube ich sagen sie telefonieren
täglich zweimal und auch immer für die
schnelle hilfe für die unterstützung
wir brauchen jetzt auch einem bündnis
der sie anpacken in deutschland dazu
können die ganzen mitarbeiter
mitarbeiter der öffentlichen verwaltung
dazu deswegen verzeihen sie auf denen
wenn manches nicht so perfekt klappt
geben uns wirklich alle mit an der
grosse mühe
und es ist doch wichtig dass bund und
länder zusammenarbeiten wenn ich das
noch sonderfall man mit einem steht ob
es schneller voran geht oder nicht wir
sind stärker betroffen
deswegen wollen wir keine zeit verzögern
und kann die zeit verschlafen aber sie
tun das auch ein stück weit für
deutschland wird es gewiss center das
ist bayern gut geht oder baden
württemberg sondern es geht um unser
ganzes land wir leben alle in einem land
und deswegen da genau man heute für die
bereitschaft ist nicht
selbstverständlich dass ein
bundesgesundheitsminister kommt
investition des bayerischen kabinetts
ist das zweite mal da und da vielen
vielen dank das ist ein zeichen auch
dass weder bayern allein gelassen wirst
du noch wie den puck allein lassen
vielen dank
wirtschaftsminister hubert aiwanger sehr
verehrten damen und herren es ist das
wichtig dass die wirtschaftliche
leistungsfähigkeit unseres landes
aufrechterhalten bleibt und dass die
betriebe durchhalten können um die
grundversorgung der bevölkerung
sicherzustellen und auch durchhalten
können und nach dieser krise ja wieder
in einen normal modus schalten zu können
arbeiten zu können
deshalb ist es zunächst mal wichtig die
momentanen herausforderungen zu
bewältigen
wir sind jetzt ganz prioritär zu
unterwegs die masken und
atemschutzmasken zu organisieren damit
im gesundheitsbereich und im
persönlichen schutzbereich genügend
ressourcen zur verfügung stehen ich
werde heute nachmittag persönlich noch
mal bei einer firma vorbeischauen und
mich vergewissern ob die für nächste
woche versprochen die lieferfähigkeit
auch wirklich kommt damit wir ab
nächster woche auch bei betrieben die
bisher andere dinge produziert haben
atemschutzmasken und nun schutz
produzieren können und in enger
zusammenarbeit mit der
gesundheitsministerin dass wir dann auch
die bestätigungen dazu bekommen die
zertifikate dazu bekommen damit diese
dinge einsatzfähig sind also da müssen
wir uns jetzt persönlich darum kümmern
und tun dass damit hier keine infos
situation auftrieb nächster punkt system
kritische infrastruktur von den banken
über den bereich energie und
wasserversorgung auch da müssen wir uns
jetzt persönlich darum kümmern und tun
das dass diese strukturen
aufrechterhalten werden
das heißt dass genügend bankschalter
auch persönlich besetzt offen bleiben
damit sie weiterhin ihre bankgeschäfte
tätigen können damit sie weiterhin an
bargeld rankommen und der bank verkehr
offen bleibt es muss ja auch das
kreditwesen bedient werden für
denjenigen die jetzt an unsere durch die
edv abgesicherten hauskredite eben über
die hausbank entgegennehmen kann
also diese dinge müssen organisatorische
offen gehalten werden bis hin eben zum
lebensmittelbereich
also auch hier der große dank an die
verkäuferin im lebensmittelbereich
genauso wie für den kundenberater in der
bank dass diese leute und vor dass der
front auch dafür geradestehen dass unser
system weiter funktioniert wir sind hier
ja mit diesen krediten jetzt schon
handlungsfähiger in unternehmer die er
jetzt finanziellen engpass situation
kommt kann jetzt schon zur hausbank
gehen dann kann dort jetzt schon einen
kredit sich holen der staatlicherseits
ja mit 500 millionen euro hier abgedeckt
ist wo wir dafür geradestehen wenn
ausfälle bei den banken wären dass die
band nicht auf diesen kredit verlusten
sitzen bleibt also der freistaat bayern
steht hier maximal zur verfügung und wir
müssen wie gesagt auch bei der
kritischen infrastruktur sei es der
bereich energieversorger und dergleichen
auch die wahren pläne fähigkeit
hergestellt haben
das heißt wenn mitarbeiter hier bei den
energieversorgern zu hause fälle hätten
oder waren das fälle hätten wo corona
auftritt das trotzdem diese
infrastruktur weiter läuft wir sind
jetzt auch daran eine arbeitskraft
plattform ins leben zu rufen in enger
zusammenarbeit mit den arbeitsagenturen
weil wir sehen dass arbeitskräfte an
einer stelle freigesetzt werden weil
arbeitsprozesse wegbrechen und an
anderer stelle beispielsweise auch im
bereich der landwirtschaft an
wirtschaftlicher hilfstätigkeiten
beginnen die sein sohn arbeiten im
hopfenbau und so weiter plötzlich
arbeitskraft rennpace sie auftreten
teilweise auch weil die arbeitskräfte
aus den ländern osteuropas teilweise in
der form nicht mehr ausreisen können
oder hier quarantänebestimmungen
auftreten wir müssen damit also sicher
stehen generell dass arbeitskräfte die
an einer stelle frei werden möglichst
auch woanders einsetzbar sind wo drinnen
der engpass an personal auftritt also
hier müssen wir auch maximale
flexibilität anwenden können damit ihr
nicht im folgeprozess ist in einigen
monaten den wirtschafts schäden
auftreten weil heute das personal
bild werden vielleicht 10 km weiter
jemand seine arbeitsstelle eben nicht
mehr besucht aus coroner gründen
das ist sehr wichtig es ist auch wichtig
für die arbeitgeber zu wissen dass die
kurzarbeiter regelung in verbesserter
form
jetzt rückwirkend ob es den märz
angewendet werden kann
das heißt wer geht personal freigesetzt
um auch den betrieb finanziell zu
entlasten und weil keine arbeit mehr da
ist kann das tun hat hier die
verbesserten bedingungen dass die
sozialkosten eben auch von der
öffentlichen hand übernommen werden und
dass er bereits auf zehn prozent
personal freisetzung in die kurzarbeit
gehen kann
ich weise auch auf das thema
steuerstundungen bei den finanzbehörden
hin wir uns so seine steuern jetzt nicht
zahlen kann oder eben eine vorauszahlung
nicht leisten will und leisten kann kann
hier bei den finanzbehörden relativ
unbürokratisch einen antrag stellen die
auch zeitnah bearbeitet wird damit die
betriebe draußen flüssig bleiben
es ist uns auch wo ist das wichtig die
angekündigte soforthilfe für cologne für
die einzelnen kleinunternehmen bis zu
250 mitarbeitern
noch in dieser woche auf den weg zu
bringen das antragsformular hierzu ist
fertig antrag auf soforthilfe kohler
hilfe zwei seiten wo die nötigen anlagen
nur getätigt werden müssen man kann es
ab morgen im internet runterladen vom
wirtschaftsministerium oder auch von den
bezirksregierungen endlos der
landeshauptstadt münchen
dann wird also der niederbayer bei der
regierung von niederbayern der oberbayer
bei der regierung von oberbayern der
münchner in münchen bei den
verwaltungsbehörden auf der seite diesen
antrag finden oder eben auch beim
wirtschaftsministerium lädt die ihn
unter füllte ihn aus muss am ende
handschriftlich unterschreiben kommt aus
rindern aber mit dem abfotografieren pdf
anhang
ein schicken aber wir brauchen noch die
handschriftliche unterschrift dann geht
das team zu den wirtschaftsförderern und
dort können dann und jetzt hören sie zu
den summen bei bis zu fünf beschäftigten
maximal 5000 euro bei bis zu zehn
beschäftigten 7500 euro bis zu 50
beschäftigte 15.000 euro bis zu 250
beschäftigte 30.000 euro sofort
abgerufen werden wenn man nicht nebenher
noch geld am konto hat natürlich und
dergleichen mehr sondern es dient
wirklich der liquiditätssicherung auch
sofort und sie werden diese woche noch
überweisungen bekommen es ist schon
angewiesen dass das finanzministerium
heute noch geld zu den regierungen gibt
dass die regierungen noch diese woche
hier gelder an die leute auszahlen
können also die ein wohn oder hin frau
betrieb der künstler der freiberufler
der traxler der jetzt wegen corona kurz
vor der insolvenz steht der messebauer
tonnen ab dieser woche in dieser woche
hier fehlt sich holen
das ist uns ist das wichtig damit wir
kurzfristig hier draußen flüssig bleiben
und nicht persönliche engpässe auftreten
also wir tun alles um das system vom
kleinen bis zum großen aufrecht zu
erhalten und für größere probleme haben
wir wie gesagt unsere staatlichen
schutzschirme entweder kredite über die
elephant die hausbank für die kleineren
und mittleren betriebe kfw kredite für
die großbetriebe aber auch das läuft
über die hausbank also gehen sie
schlichtweg zu ihrer hausbank und für
größere probleme wo betriebe in
schieflage kommen die wir für
systemrelevant halten kann die man auch
der freistaat bayern über staatliche
beteiligung in reihen gehen das würden
wir dann natürlich im einzelfall sehr
genau prüfen ob das nötig ob das
sinnvoll ist aber es besteht auch die
möglichkeit sollte es zu größeren
verwerfungen in der wirtschaft kommen
dass der freistaat bayern hier seinen
schutzmantel auch über einzelne betriebe
darüber legt und sagt ich will dass der
betrieb weiterläuft ich gehe
freistaat bayern mit einem anteil der 1
gesundheitsministerin welt gekommen
wir haben eine sehr geehrten damen und
herren
die lage ist ernst ich habe das schon
gestern und vorgestern gesagt und wir
müssen auch entschlossen darauf
reagieren und das ist heute 1060
personen in bayern erkrankt am corona
virus und bereits fünf personen
verstorben
und deswegen ist es notwendig diese
maßnahmen zu ergreifen und das sehr
vieles schon vom ministerpräsidenten
angesprochen worden
deswegen möchte ich es hier nämlich kurz
fassen an dieser stelle heute und vor
allem auch dem
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen für
die gute zusammenarbeit danken auch mit
den anderen gesundheitsministern der
länder sind wir im ständigen austausch
wo es in welche massnahmen angezeigt und
in bayern dadurch dass die wir natürlich
die ersten fälle hatten war es auch
immer wichtig dass wir da einen schritt
voraus gehen und zeigen was eben auch
entscheidend ist hier die dinge mit
voranzubringen
ich für mich ist wichtig wenn wir schon
diese tief schneiden maßnahmen für die
gesamtbevölkerung mit schulschließungen
kindergarten was alles im
gastronomiebereich und und und jetzt
vorgesehen ist dass wir dabei aber nicht
nachlassen das ist das was die
gesamtbevölkerung leistet und das ist
wirklich enorm und deswegen dürfen wir
auf der anderen seite da wo wir wissen
dass das betroffene gibt dass es
patienten gibt es kontaktpersonen gibt
auch nicht nachlassen
deswegen bin ich sehr dankbar dass wir
noch mal 400 zusätzliche menschen an
personal bekommen um die
gesundheitsämter die behörden vor ort zu
unterstützen weil das ist notwendig
damit wir bei der strategie dass wir
diejenigen auch erfassen wollen die
betroffenen sind denen sagen wollen
bleibt punkte 14 tage wirklich komplett
zu hause um hier die infektionsketten
auch wirklich zu abzubrechen und nicht
weiter gehen zu lassen
die maßnahmen müssen zusammen
das gesamt beförderung tut aber wir
dürfen auch im verwaltungshandeln wenn
es um eindämmen geht nicht nachlassen
und das ist unsere aufgabe und das
werden wir tun das robert-koch-institut
hat ja die gefährdungslage hochgestuft
für deutschland das zeigt dass es eben
auch notwendig war diese maßnahmen
entsprechend zu fahren und alle weiteren
können sie auch bei uns auf der homepage
die allgemeinverfügungen nachlesen
die dann erst ab heute nachmittag dort
auch einsehbar sind wenn es noch fragen
gibt was heißt das zu besuchen in
pflegeheimen was heißt es im
gastronomiebereich und und und dann
bitte da sich informieren und
nachschauen
das sind die eben auch entsprechend
eingestellt vielen herzlichen dank an
alle nicht die gesamtbevölkerung aber
vor allem auch an diejenigen die gerade
im gesundheits und pflegebereich tätig
sind die apothekerinnen die weiterhin
geöffnet haben werden auch hier keine
angst die versorgungslage wird auch hier
weiter aufrechterhalten
an alle die in den verschiedenen
bereichen auch im öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und und und enormes
leisten die die ganzen testungen vorne
mit die laborkapazitäten die wir
erweitern und und und vielen herzlichen
dank an alle aber auch an die
allgemeinbevölkerung machen sie mit bei
nur so können wir es schaffen
dann kommen wir zu den ersten fragen zum
anfang gleich einen ministerpräsidenten
von jürgen umlauft gibt es überlegungen
maßnahmen gegen die offensichtlich
unnötigen hamsterkäufe zu ergreifen
ob zb der erlass einer führungsaufgabe
grenze für bestimmte produkte angedacht
ist
das ist derzeit nicht geplant scheint
uns auch nicht notwendig wie gesagt für
treffen zusammen mit dem lebensmittel
versorgern und darüber zu reden
dahinter haben gespräch mit dem
logistiker nach derzeitigem stand sieht
es so aus dass die
lebensmittelversorgung ausreichend
gesichert ist deswegen gibt es da kein
anders ich kann nur appellieren das
nicht zu machen zumal verschiedene
sachen dann auch nicht gebraucht wenn es
macht keinen sinn in sachen zu kaufen
die man entweder dann wegschmeißen muss
oder niemals auf brauchen wird und
andere können es dringend gebrauchen was
uns allerdings wichtig ist erste
entscheidende punkte im moment
die freiheit der waren und der
lieferverkehr sicherzustellen
deswegen wäre eine solche busspur eine
fahrspur an der grenze eine kleine spur
ganz existenziell wichtig denn wir leben
so dass durch die grenzkontrollen sich
das da verzögert wir wollen ja klar
unterscheiden beim grenze zwischen
leuten die normal einreisen wollen dass
touristen und denen die als pendler
möglicherweise im moment waren grenz
umfeld wichtig sind denn insbesondere
waren und lieferverkehr das ist jetzt
die aufgabe das bayerische kabinett
bietet jetzt auch den bund da der stelle
mit der bundespolizei das miteinander
gut und auch vernünftig zu lösen
die nächste frage richtet sich an herrn
sparen
für wie sinnvoll werden die ankündigung
der deutschen bahn erachtet weniger
ausgelastete züge zu streichen mit der
konsequenz dass die weiter verkehrenden
züge voller besetzt wären die deutsche
bahn waren zu beginn von beginn an beim
auch krisenstab des innen- und des
gesundheitsministers auf bundesebene
immer mit eingebunden ein
ansprechpartner ich habe sie immer auch
als der vorausschauend plant er lebt in
allen diskussionen
deswegen gehe ich davon aus dass bei
allen maßnahmen so wie gehabt auch
darauf geachtet wird dass eben abstände
eingehalten werden können soweit es eben
möglich ist gerade im fernverkehr und
eben auch jene regelungen getroffen
werden was wir in teilen eben aber auch
erleben das gilt für den flugverkehr
noch mehr ist ja dass generell
jedenfalls im fernverkehr deutlich
weniger reisen stattfinden was auch gut
ist was sehr wichtig und gewollt lässt
sich übrigens für den nahverkehr wo ich
gerade münchen und damit in einer großen
stadt auch bin wo das vielleicht auch
leichter möglich ist bei dem wetter das
wir gerade ist sowieso auch nur und das
nicht nur als gesundheitsminister lenz
und bewegung geht sondern gerade auch in
diesen zeiten wo es um die vermeidung
von ansteckungen geht und zu vollen oder
s-bahn geht sie auch nur ermuntern kann
im zweifel so weit es eben möglich ist
zu fuß zu gehen oder mit dem rad zu
fahren
auch das vermeidet ansteckt die nächsten
fragen gehen haben die
gesundheitsministerin aus bayern melanie
huml von anni bliesdorf bayerische
rundfunk wie steht es um die versorgung
mit
mal gucken im stoff der soll in bayern
fast aus sein
und wenn man sich testen lassen will wie
das genaue prozedere abläuft wer sollte
unbedingt sich testen lassen
gibt es neue veränderungen und wen ruft
man an den hausarzt das gesundheitsamt
und wo kann man sich auch testen lassen
als im prinzip das prozedere zu den
tests bei den testungen ist es so dass
wir sehr viel wert darauf legen werden
dass ich wirklich symptomatische also
hier niemand krankheitssymptome hat dass
der jene getestet wird weil wir vielfach
testungen im moment haben wenn du jemand
den eindruck hat ich bin angehustet
worten könnte ich angesteckt sein und
dadurch aber die laborkapazitäten die
eben auch nur im begrenzten umfang der
weiten sie zwar täglich fast aus aber
trotzdem da sind dass wir dann eben
schauen wollen dass die die
symptomatisch sind die wirklich geben
auch hier kontakt hatten mit patienten
dass wir hier verstärkt wert darauf
legen dass die jetzt mit symptomatischer
symptomen die krank sind auch getestet
werden können und dass die ein stück
weit vorrang haben auch diejenigen wenn
jemand einem krankenhaus im pflegeheim
arbeitet oder eben müssen müssen sehr
schnell ob derjenige auch wenn ein
kontakt hatte erkrankt das war wir ihn
eben in der versorgung brauchen vom
prozedere ist es so wenig kontakt hatte
mit einem der erkrankt war
dann melde ich mich beim gesundheitsamt
wenn ich eher den verdacht nur bei mir
nach krankheitssymptomen verspüren dann
melde ich mich beim hausarzt bitte
telefonisch nicht direkt in die praxis
laufen oder eben über die 11 6 11 7 die
wir auch noch mal verstärken werden weil
wir nach wie vor hören dass es leider zu
wartezeiten kommt ich habe aber auch
mitbekommen dass die kassenärztliche
vereinigung mehr zeit hat dass sie auch
den letzten tagen auf bundesebene zum
teil auch technische schwierigkeiten
hatten dass jemand aus der leitung
geworfen wurde
weil die leitung einfach so überlastet
war dass das ganze system ist nicht mehr
gepackt hat das ist nicht nur am
personal lag sondern einfach auch an
diesen technischen dingen aber auch
daran wird gearbeitet
was die kapazitäten
mal gucken impfstoff betrifft da ist es
so dass sie mir in den letzten wochen
und monaten ja auch verstärkt auch die
ärzte dazu aufgerufen haben sich gegen
pneumokokken impfen zu lassen eben um
wenn man sozusagen nicht nur wenn man
die gefahr hat corona infiziert zu
werden und gleichzeitig von pneumokokken
dann wäre ja die lunge sozusagen als
beides zu lungenentzündungen führen kann
doppelt belastet und deswegen war eben
die empfehlung gewesen gerade für
menschen älteren alters sich eben gegen
pneumokokken impfen zu lassen das haben
sehr viele genutzt deswegen ist es
korrekt dass es da zu einem gewissen
engpass im moment kommt was sind name
pocken impfstoff betrifft aber ich
glaube es ist eben wichtig dass
diejenigen die schon geimpft sind ja den
schutzmann haben anwohner versuchen wir
mit den maßnahmen dass wir diese
infektion verlangsamen um dann auch die
behandlungsmöglichkeiten hoch stoppen zu
können
wenn ich noch kurz zwei zahlen und
ergänzen darf man für die größenordnung
wir haben im letzten der letzten woche
von über 100000 tests gehabt in
deutschland auf corona allein bei den
kassenärztlichen laboren
das dürfte mehr sein als in den
allermeisten anderen ländern auf der
welt und ich weiß dass es immer noch im
alltag situationen gibt wo jemand auf
den test wartet und warten muss aber ich
will mit der zahl aber auch deutlich
machen dass wir schon sehr hohen
kapazitäten haben es gleichzeitig aber
wichtig bleibt das eben wie auch vor
allem die tests auf die konzentrieren wo
es auch angezeigt ist und das zweite 11
6 11 7 es angesprochen worden
das ist ja die telefonnummern auch der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung eigentlich
ja die nummer die seit dem ersten per
gesetz für 24 stunden sieben tage die
woche zur verfügung steht da gab es in
der woche ist sache weit über 400.000
anrufe die entgegengenommen wurden
werden konnten
aber es trotzdem kommt es immer wieder
zu wartezeiten
wir sind ja sehr froh und dankbar das
möchte ich gerne auch weiter zu
ermuntern auch auf unseren
internetseiten dass sich viele
bürgerinnen und bürger informieren
wollen
zur wahrheit wird aber eben auch wenn
viele sich gleichzeitig
informieren kann selbst bei der hotline
mit der größten kapazität die wir haben
und über 400.000 anrufe in einer woche
sind schon ziemlich eine große
größenordnung irgendwann auch
wartezeiten entstehen und da kann ich
einmal mehr dann auch einfach nur um
geduld und verständnis bitten in bayern
sind etwa täglich 6000 anrufe die über
die 11 6 11 7 abgewickelt werden
und das ist natürlich auch einiges
wasser hier eine kapazität gefunden wird
wir haben eine fülle von fragen des
wegen der zuruf an die journalisten
benötigen die runde dann schließen der
fragen aber es wir haben noch etliche
auf dem zettel
eine nachfrage gleich an fragen wie
viele drei vier teststationen gibt es
momentan in bayern und wie viele sind
noch geplant
also wir sind etwa an die 20 bekannt und
wir es so dass einige landkreise ist
selbstständig organisiert haben das
einige von der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung betrieben werden vor allem
hier in münchen in nürnberg demnächst
entdecken oder ab heute entdecken darf
also dass hier auch die kvb sich mit
beteiligt und auch weitere eröffnen wird
und das sind einige zum beispiel
landkreis bamberg scheßlitz die schon
sich die geräte betrieben wurde also es
gibt einige die schon jetzt ganz aktiv
laufen und es werden weitere folgen
ergänzend werden heute im kabinett die
gesamten kommunalen spitzenverbände da
einschließlich oberbürgermeister land
ist auch schon wir haben zig
einzelprobleme besprochen im abgleich im
täglichen abgleich bestimmte
testmaterial
es braucht bestimmte möglichkeiten der
schutzmasken wie das weitergeht wie wir
die abgleichung machen bei der
wirtschaftsförderung also wir zumindest
eins zu eins sind gleichklang zu machen
mit den kommunen damit auch da kein
problem existiert wir wollen es dass
staat sich als ganzes handlungsfähig
aber ist deswegen heute praktisch die
komplette staatliche entscheidungsträger
bei einander mit dem bund dem land und
den kommunen alle fokussiert auf dieses
thema ich weiß nicht wie es mit dem
zeitmanagement aussieht ersparen
und dann würde ich eventuell fragen ans
ufer ziehen wir können
dann kriegen sie trotzdem die nächste
frage von wolfgang ranft bild bayern
unternimmt starke anstrengungen und die
verbreitung der infektionen einzudämmen
wie können sie sicherstellen dass ganz
deutschland einheitlich handelt müssen
alle bundesländer den katastrophenfall
erklären und mit welcher zahl von
infektionen müssen wir in deutschland
rechnen wir haben ja bei den maßnahmen
die jetzt ergriffen wurden sowohl bei
den schließungen der kindergärten und
schulen wie auch bei der frage wie ist
es mit öffentlichen einrichtungen
gaststätten clubs diskotheken messen
veranstaltungen sportveranstaltungen
also ihren sehr umfangreichen katalog
gestern noch in einer telefonschalte der
bundesregierung mit den
ministerpräsidenten uns auf einheitliche
linie geeinigt und dafür braucht es wie
gesagt immer auch welche die das mit
vorantreiben der ist markus söder und
der freistaat bayern auf jeden fall
einer auch aus der betroffenheit heraus
eben durch die nähe zu österreich und
italien
ja sehr sehr früh eben auch eine
entwicklung die es so in anderen
bundesländern noch nicht gibt und das
ist das was ich vorhin sagte ich
verstehe dass manche sagen es braucht
manchmal ein zwei tage bis vielleicht
der föderale staat entscheidungen trifft
und woanders werden die in zwei stunden
getroffen aber das ist meine feste
überzeugung wenn wir gemeinsam bund und
länder eine entscheidung getroffen haben
wie zum beispiel die zu kindergarten
schulschließung oder der frage jetzt
auch aufzubauen intensiv kapazität nun
krankenhäuser dann haben sie eben auch
16 mal die struktur die kapazität die
ministerien die regierung aber auch alle
die die im vorort die dinge besser
einschätzen können deswegen sehr dankbar
dass die kommunalen spitzenverbände
heute dabei waren das dann auch
umzusetzen und das ist dann eine stärke
des föderalen staates und in welcher
struktur dass der jeweilige staat macht
der bund die bundesländer das ist dann
natürlich entscheidung der jeweiligen
landesregierung christina heller
augsburger allgemeine zeitung zwei
fragen wer kann die soforthilfen denn
alles beantragen
ob es zum beispiel einschränkungen auch
gibt für kulturschaffende oder
freiberufliche und noch eine frage im
gewahrsam ministerpräsidenten dann die
rehaklinik
die kliniken sollen intensivbetten
verhalten was dies genau bedeutet wird
der betrieb dort eingeschränkt und wie
viele betten sollen insgesamt geschaffen
werden also soforthilfen kann jeder
unternehmerisch tätige und freiberufler
beantragen auch der fotograf der frist
sie hat ihren mann und ein frau betrieb
sofern nicht anderweitig noch liegt wie
dies also nicht als taschengeld nebenher
und ist ganz klar zu sagen sondern wenn
das konto leer ist wenn man keine
aktiendepot kein gold mehr zu hause hat
sondern wenn man schlicht wegen momentan
nicht mehr liquide ist und die gefahr
besteht aus eben das unternehmen damit
geschlossen werden muss kann man ab
morgen beide in der regierungen eben
diesen antrag stellen und bekommt diese
woche noch geld bis 250 mitarbeiter auf
das ist der vortrag möchte mal
ausführlich dankeschön
wir haben das ja gemeinsam abgewogen und
überlegt aus der richtige weg die
massnahmen des bundes die da gut sind
werden aber eher den größeren netzen und
denen die auch etwas zeit haben über den
langen weg zu gehen über die banken über
die kfw und so weiter sind die relativ
aufwendige verfahren ist was wir jetzt
machen das ist die erfahrung nicht
persönlich getroffen habe und erfahren
habe aus der flut damals zuständig für
das krisen-management da ging es um die
frage eine soforthilfe soforthilfe ist
das wichtigste
wenn der staat geschäfte schließt und
zwangsweise an arbeitet wenn der staat
das öffentliche leben runter fährt dann
muss er auch die instrumente bin dass
die wirtschaft und die menschen dabei
ihr leben ganz entscheidend und darum
jetzt auch die große summe mit dem
medizin milliarden mit der soforthilfe
und zwar für dich jeder kann das sammeln
der unternehmerisch tätig ist jeder muss
eben das formular ausfüllen muss aber
auch nachweisen dass er den bedarf hat
der wird dann irgendwann sicherlich
überprüft das heißt übernimmt auch die
haftung dafür dass die lage tatsächlich
so ist also wieder glücksritter muss
wissen das wird nicht funktionieren
aber das geht vom einmannbetrieb über
auch betriebe die jetzt beispielsweise
wir schränken friseure ein und viele
andere auch die müssen dann ja mit
erheblichen einbußen rechnen
und dafür hilfen wir diese helfen diese
überbrückungen zu machen
das ist das eine sehr wichtige maßnahme
bitte noch mal die zeit weg zu sehen ab
morgen ist formular ab freitag kann wenn
es die prüfzeit von den regierungen und
in münchen der landeshauptstadt und auch
dankbar sind dass sie damit hilft kann
da bereits aus zahna von irgendwo in
deutschland
ich hoffe ich im connect muss wir den
kollegen aber nirgendwo deutschland gibt
es eine so schnelle direkte
unbürokratisch und in der höhe ist es
substanzielle hilfe
aber das machen wir und auch da ist zu
überlegen ob wir nicht in deutschland
generell solche prinzipien stärker
machen denn es geht nicht nur die großen
betriebe zu schützen sondern auch die
ganz kleinen und mittelständischen
betriebe das ist wirklich ganz wichtig
und kultur schaffen übrigens auch gerade
in münchen leben von der hand in den
mund nahm
theater kabarett kreativ bereiche die
leben wirklich von der hand in den mund
die liquidität in den nicht sehr hoch
und die sollen auch das kulturleben soll
nicht zu kunde kennt ganz bewegt und
vielleicht verpackungen noch mit der
frage ob der reha beträgt betrieb
eingeschränkt wird und wie viele betten
auf diese weise geschaffen werden also
der reha betrieb soll eingeschränkt
werden das ist richtig wir wollen auch
die reha kliniken mit aufnehmen in das
konzept wenn es darum geht eben hier
betten zu schaffen auch notfall betten
und intensivbetten bzw
wir brauchen ja auch für die
normalbevölkerung die vielleicht eben
mit einem herzinfarkt kommt die
dringender kaiserschnitt nötig ist oder
oder oder weiter kapazitäten und
deswegen ist es notwendig alle
stationären einrichtungen mit
einzubeziehen
wir hoffen dass die rehakliniken dann
auch unter dem schirm des bundes
mitkommen dürfen der krankenhäuser dass
es eine bitte an den entspannten auch
heute ausgesprochen haben weil wir
natürlich auch hier dann belastung haben
für die reha träger und wir werden
entsprechend mit aufnehmen kann ich
vielleicht noch kurz ergänzen ich hab
den kliniken jahr am donnerstag nach der
entscheidung der ministerpräsidenten der
bundesregierung dass kliniken alle
planbaren op es sind aufnahmen
verschieben sollen bis auf weiteres um
eben kapazitäten jetzt frühzeitig zu
gewinnen für mögliche intensiv und
beatmungspatienten dass wir natürlich
gleichzeitig auch nur finanzielle sich
halt geben müssen dass die kliniken die
jetzt damit ja auch auf erlöse und
umsatz verzichten damit nicht in eine
wirtschaftliche schieflage geraten
mein plan ist es spätestens anfang
nächster woche idealerweise in dieser
woche dazu ein konkretes konzept und an
auch schon gesetzgebung vorzulegen das
wollen wir zügig machen weil diejenigen
planungssicherheit brauchen und das gilt
natürlich dann auch mit blick auf reha
kliniken die filme ergänzen wenn planbar
op es dürfte zum beispiel oder knie
operationen verschoben werden dann ist
natürlich auch in reha-einrichtungen in
der folge eine geringere patientenzahl
und es gibt ja dann auch die möglichkeit
geben sie mit zu nutzen auch für die
akutversorgung nicht erwartet
deutschlandfunk es gebe rückmeldungen
aus kliniken in münchen dass die zahl
der einlieferungen deutlich steigt ob
das für ganz bayern zutreffe oder nur
für münchen
und was die staatsregierung unternehme
um die kapazitäten am beatmungsgeräten
zu erhöhen
und nochmal zudem bargeld erhöhungen
erwähnt wurden
ob da auch bei einschränkungen geplant
seien im notfall bargeldabhebungen
also nachdem die fälle steigen die
anzeige hat gesagt wissen jetzt bei 1260
für bayern
und wenn wir davon ausgehen können dass
80 prozent eher milde verlaufen heißt es
aber auch dass 20% eben entsprechende
kapazitäten brauchen da wir die meisten
fälle nach wie vor in oberbayern haben
und im schwäbischen bereich es im
südbayerischen es ist hier natürlich so
dass die krankenhaus kapazitäten als
erstes auch hier das spüren wenn die
patienten aufgenommen werden müssen
deswegen ja ich höre dass auch aus dem
südbayerischen raum dort in landkreisen
wo natürlich auch weniger fälle sind
sind entsprechend auch die kapazitäten
oder krankenhäuser noch komplett frei
von corona patienten gleichzeitig ist es
so dass wir eben ich habe das
eben die kapazitäten auch im
intensivbereich hochfahren wir haben
eben beatmungsgeräte auch bestellt wenn
es gut läuft kommen die essen 48 auch
schon heute oder die nächsten tage an
also sprich wir sind da wirklich dran
das zu unterstützen
wir sind aber auch und das ist notwendig
mit dieser meldepflicht für
beatmungsgeräte weil es gibt eben auch
beatmungsgeräte die stehen jetzt nicht
mehr unbedingt im klinikum aber die sind
vielleicht eben in der praxis oder einer
praxisklinik und können auch genutzt
werden
und deswegen brauchen wir unter sehen
war die grundlage die wir heute im
kabinett gelegt haben so wichtig dass
wir eben hier durchgreifen können dass
wir bis zur beschlagnahmung gehen können
wenn es eben auch notwendig werden
sollte aber dafür müssen wir erst mal
wissen wo werde ich es sind und dafür
die meldepflicht baugeld ist derzeit
nicht geplant dass die ist höchstgrenzen
der abhebung gibt es gibt ja bei vielen
das tageslimit und sie können aus dem
automaten nicht mehr raus lassen
bis auf weiteres nicht geplant aber wir
haben heute ein bomben gespräch ist es
auf alle fälle die durchhaltefähigkeit
der banken zu gewährleisten
die schalter müssen in ausreichender
form offen bleiben natürlich müssen wir
auch die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter maximal schützen heißt alles
was online geht bitte auch so erledigen
aber derzeit keine obergrenze geplant
christoph trost dpa
laut krankenhausgesellschaft gehen den
ersten kliniken in bayern ende der woche
die masken und schutzkleidung aus
nachschub sei offen ob dies zutreffe und
wie die lage sei
das ist objektiv eine situation die wir
ja auch schon seit drei vier wochen
diskutieren das problem ist dass in
krankenhäuser staaten privatpersonen auf
der ganzen welt masken gekauft haben
auch weit über das notwendige hinaus
übrigens privatpersonen brauchen für
ihren alltag weder masken noch
desinfektionsmittel beides bitte lassen
für den medizinischen betrieb da werden
sie dringend gebraucht
ich bin dankbar dass auch der freistaat
bayern ja schaut wer entsprechende
ausrüstung beschaffen kann
wir machen das auch ich persönlich sehr
sehr intensiv eben seit drei wochen
und wie es ausschaut werden wir auch in
den nächsten tagen dort konkret zur
lösung kommen die wahrheit ist aber auch
ich möchte es erst damit umgehen wenn
ich weiß dass es auch bei uns hier in
deutschland angekommen ist die
entsprechende ware
denn das ist am ende auch das was
vertrauen und verlässlichkeit gibt dass
wenn dann ist auch tatsächlich da und
verfügbar ist aber ich weiß sehr um die
situation in den praxen in den kliniken
in vielen anderen bereichen
pflegeeinrichtungen wenn es um den
mangel an diesen masken geht das ist ein
thema ich finde übrigens die initiative
hier in bayern die wir auch im bund
insgesamt überlegen auch wieder
produktionskapazitäten in deutschland zu
haben eine sehr richtige und wichtige
was wir alle spüren in diesen tagen und
wochen ist dass wir nicht in diesem
umfang
gerade bei solch sensiblen produkten
auch arzneimitteln masken aber auch in
den lieferketten abhängig sein sollten
vor allem von einem großen land nämlich
china und das ist in jedem fall eine
lehre dieser wochen denke ich auch dort
die abhängigkeit zu reduzieren für
europa also das sind alle da hinterher
es zu versuchen
wir haben alles das was menschen
mögliches gemacht aber fest steht auch
wir brauchen künftig eine
notfallapotheke im land was medizinische
einrichtung betrifft auch was
materialien betrifft und eine kritische
notwendige infrastruktur die das
herstellen kann wenn es ernst wird also
für pandemiepläne der zukunft muss es
die möglichkeit
geben direkte aktivierung und
reaktivieren von produktionskapazitäten
zu geben wir sind es in bayern dran mit
dem unternehmen allen beteiligten danke
schön aber so kann es nicht mehr bleiben
daran schließt sich an die frage von
katja süddeutsche zeitung welche firmen
künftig atemschutzmasken herstellen
sollen und was bisher produziert wurde
und wie die staatsregierung ihre eigene
handlungsfähigkeit sicherstelle
beziehungsweise die gesundheit der
kabinettsmitglieder
also wir haben eine reihe von firmen die
ich aber jetzt nicht namentlich
verkünden werde die ab nächster woche in
die produktion einsteigen
teilweise aus dem textilbereich und
dergleichen mehr also aus verwandten
branchen die ab nächster woche sowohl
atemschutz als auch mundschutz in großer
zahl hier stellen werden auch sehr viel
wert darauf gelegt dass wir versuchen
die abstände zwischen den räumliche
möglichkeiten auch das kabinett zu
wesentlich voneinander sitzen müssen und
und und aber sonst gilt natürlich auch
für das kabinett dasselbe wie für die
allgemeinbevölkerung zutrifft dh eben
möglichst wenig kontakte mit anderen
jetzt auch nicht irgendwelche
veranstaltungen sind ja alles abgesagt
worden
die hier gehen die maßnahmen die für
alle mitglieder hier bei uns im land
gelten gelten natürlich auch für die
kabinettsmitglieder dem maße von daher
habe ich auch den kollegen immer wieder
erzählt was sind für hygienemaßnahmen
und soweit notwendig sind und dass das
entsprechend dann auch umgesetzt wird
wir sind ganz normale bürger wir halten
uns an alt ist was wir empfehlen
es gibt keine sonderregelung wieder von
bundesminister managers sein darf noch
vermissten landesminister jeder hat sich
an die gleiche
jeder muss seine vorsorge entsprechend
treffen und es ist auch wichtig dass wir
alle zusammen halten ist after keine
zwei klassen geben also die werden da an
unseren alles alten abstand halten
händel war schon so oft es nur geht und
einfach achtgeben händeschütteln sowieso
schon lange nicht mehr und einfach acht
geben auf das umfeld das ist glaube ich
das ganz entscheidende
da kann jeder einen beitrag leisten und
eben auch denjenigen deswegen zb wenn
wir jetzt in unseren parks den schönen
wetter ist ja ein klar dass der
englische garten und andere parks voll
sind wir werden deswegen an verschiedene
aufstellen wir bitten auch die
mitarbeiter der parks durch die parks zu
gehen und bisschen einfach um mitarbeit
zu bieten was man keine riesenrad ist
dann draußen veranstaltet das ist jetzt
die zeit der einschränkung für alle ja
aber das bisschen einschränken kann
einen ganz großen effekt haben und leben
retten
dass sie noch mal eine große bitte keine
hamsterkäufe keine unnötigen
bargeldabhebungen nichts was den
allgemeinen betrieb zusätzlich
herausfordert jeder ist jetzt zeit einer
großen gemeinschaft und bitte jeder muss
seinen beitrag bringen
wir haben jetzt noch fragen von drei
lilien christine schröpf
mittelbayerische zeitung in ländern wie
marokko sind auch viele bayerische
urlauber gestrandet die keine
pauschalreise gebucht haben
sie fürchten bei der rückholaktion des
bundes nicht inbegriffen zu sein
die deutschen botschaften seien
überlastet ob bayern ein eigenes
notfalltelefon einrichten soll oder
würde oder eventuell auch über alkohol
ab rückhol aktionen planen würde
und dann gibt es da eine frage zur
stichwahl zur hygiene bei der
kommunalwahl die wahlhelfer würden
fürchten sich doch briefumschläge zu
infizieren
die mit spucke zugeklebt worden sind die
staatsregierung das infektionsrisiko
einschätze und welche vorsichtsmaßnahmen
zu treffen sein sollten
es kommen noch zwei danach so etwas zu
dem bundes aktivitäten die gerade eine
zeitung
das auswärtige amt bemüht sich gerade
darum ja auch mit charter kapazitäten da
wo keine linienverbindungen mehr sind
und wo die jeweiligen länder wie marokko
auf den linien verkehren eingestellt
haben bundesbürger zurück und ihre
familien zurück nach deutschland zu
bringen natürlich auch die bayerischen
bundesbürger zurück nach deutschland zu
bringen
es sind in marokko aktuell wenn ich es
richtig im kopf 5000 um die es geht
und natürlich wird das auswärtige amt
jetzt alles daran setzen diese bürger
zurück zu bringen aber auch da ist
manchmal ebenso aufgrund der großen zahl
dass an manchen stellen dann geduld etwa
wenn es um telefon erreichbarkeit geht
angesagt ist aber wir sind schon sehr
sehr bewusst als bundesregierung um die
verantwortung ist natürlich auch die
bürgerinnen und bürger die im ausland
teilweise eben auch bei reisen
gestrandet sind so muss man es sagen
weil eben jetzt die rückkehr
möglichkeiten nicht da sind natürlich
jetzt zurück zu uns nach deutschland zu
bringen
zu prüfen ist unanständig
bisher ist die aussage der biologen das
eben wenn es über gegenstände und so
weiter geht eigentlich keine anstellung
potenzial da ist wir werden das
sicherlich noch mal auch mit den
experten besprechen ob irgendeiner form
ein risiko da sein sollte ansonsten ist
es sicherlich im die briefwahl
die möglichkeit dass ich auch möglichst
wenig kontakte mit den menschen da sind
aber das würde er noch mal prüfen lassen
die vorletzte frage von alexander kain
stimmt die folgende feststellung
österreicher oder schweizer dürfen nicht
ins land tirana und genießen schon
die europäische union hat ja gerade eben
auch die einreise aus drittel in der eu
nun ich gut nicht eu länder anders
ländern beschränkt zu recht beschränkt
um dort eben auch vor allem
ausschließlich nur noch eu-bürger bürger
mit dauerhaften aufenthaltsrecht und
bestimmte gruppen diplomaten ärzte hier
nach europa einreisen zu lassen
insofern sind das entsprechende
maßnahmen die eben auch richtig und
wichtig sind auch mit blick darauf was
andere länder machen und wie das
ausbruchsgeschehen ist ich will aber ein
schon auch dazu sagen welcher die
öffentliche debatte dazu waren immer
dies richtig die maßnahmen sind richtig
weil das ausbruchsgeschehen dass wir im
moment haben hat viel zu tun mit den
rückkehrern aus dem skiurlaub südtirol
österreich schweiz und deswegen weil ich
schon am wochenende dazu aufgerufen dass
alle die zurückkehren
aus dem urlaub so weit es geht zu hause
bleiben für zwei wochen oder wenn sie zu
arbeiten müssen dann eben auf sich und
auch andere auch aufpassen in der frage
wie man sich dann eben verhält wie man
abstand hält und anderes aus anderes
mehr also es ist wichtig ja die
maßnahmen ergreifen wir ja auch die
einreisen aus bestimmten denn dann noch
weiter einzuschränken oder gar nicht
mehr möglich zu machen aber ich bitte
auch nicht zu unterschätzen das risiko
dass gerade auch entstanden ist aus der
aus dem see regen austausch den es in
den skigebieten gegeben hat und aus den
skigebieten heraus diese entwicklung
dann sich in ganz europa verbreitet hat
viel von dem ausbruchsgeschehen in dem
markt zb er hat zu tun auch und
ausschließlich mit rückkehrern aus dem
skigebiet und deswegen doch mal die
bitte an alle dieser zurückgekehrt sind
soweit es eben geht zu hause zu bleiben
andere zu schützen und wenn symptome
sich zeigen natürlich den arzt
telefonisch zu kontaktieren
ich bin froh dass das in europa jetzt
stattfindet es war ehrlich sind
überfällig nicht sagen letzten tage aber
noch mal mein appell ist wirklich jetzt
zum wiederholten male haben es auch
wieder nachrichten bekommen das ist
jetzt corona partys gibt von
jugendlichen
nicht also bitte wenn die polizei wird
sowas dann auch entsprechend unterbinden
wenn der riesen partys gefeiert werden
und darauf hinweist dass so etwas nicht
machen kann weil es einfach eine
wirkliche gefährdung ist bitte einfach
unterlassen jetzt mal alle zusammen
halten
im kleinen trick kann man jetzt alles
machen es kommt bei der sommer wer weiß
wie die situation dann ist wie wenn das
alles beobachten aber jetzt jeder seinen
beitrag und auch selbst wenn man nicht
große symptome spüren würde man kann die
großeltern man kann die eltern
ansteckend man kann bekannte anstecken
und wer möchte denn dafür verantwortlich
sein zum abschluss wohl an englisch
nürnberger nachrichten
die testergebnisse laufen viele tests
einige tage hinterher
wie groß ist der abstand zwischen test
und ergebnis für welchen tag gelten die
aktuell genannten zahlen und wie viele
der erfassten krankheits und
infektionsfälle mittlerweile wieder
genesen sind
vielleicht durch grundsätzlich normal
also das ist so dass mit jedem tag den
wir die entwicklung haben den anderen
europäischen und allen ländern auf der
welt auch der unterschied zwischen dem
was wir statistisch erfassen können wo
wir auch einfach noch nach halten können
durch testung und dem was wahrscheinlich
auch an zusätzlichen infektionen da ist
die gar nicht bemerkt werden weil auch
keine symptome sich ergeben dass diese
unterschied immer größer wird versuchen
ihn so klein wie möglich zu halten wie
gesagt wir machen
bezogen auf die einwohnerzahl mehr tests
wie wahrscheinlich nur wenige wie wenig
andere länder auf der welt mehr test als
viele andere aber dass dieser
unterschied wird größer werden das
gehört zur wahrheit dazu und es gibt
eine zeitverzögerung in den meldungen
auch deswegen ist es so wichtig dass es
die 400 zusätzlichen mitarbeiter aus
landesbehörden zum öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst in bayern in die
landkreise hinein gibt denn zum teil
geht es ihnen einfach schlicht und
ergreifend darum dass auch zu erfassen
und zu melden
das kostet zeit und wenn man gerade eben
natürlich mit anderen dringlicheren
belastet ist bleibt das manchmal legen
deswegen hilft das eben auch die
statistik denn aktuell aktueller zu
halten was ich wichtig finde das ist
angesprochen ist die frage wie viele
sind gesundet da haben wir eben keine
mail
pflicht ist auch schwer nachzuvollziehen
aber es lässt sich ja eigentlich
mathematisch herleiten und da wollte ich
das robert-koch-institut auch
beauftragen dass man für uns zu machen
denn bei denen die 43 46 wochen als
positiv gemeldet wurden und wo sich
keine krankheitssymptome und kein
behandlungsbedarf der länger anhält
ergeben hat die müssen ja nach aller
logik er mittlerweile gesundet sein und
das lässt sich errechnen und berechnen
und ich dann noch diese zahl ist wichtig
für die einordnung für die bürgerinnen
und bürger eben auch zu sehen wie viele
tatsächlich ohne größere probleme wieder
virenfrei gesundet sind dann schließen
wir die pressekonferenz herzlichen dank
nochmal fürs mitmachen
trotzdem an den schirmen die umstände
sind besonders und herzlichen dank auch
nochmal einkommen ist
gesundheitsminister philipp ist